bishop d7 rook e5 it's not even that  you're losing material you also continue  getting mated queen f8 rook h5 i think  is just made  i i don't think you survive another five  moves here  uh  and instead of this they've already  repeated twice  or maybe even three times  three times ah if he could claim his  knight d7 did he claim  oh well that's a big question because if  he could have claimed definitely he  would have yeah it's uh  ah they are signing yes wow okay but  this is a big relief because this is a  happy ending first of all faisal makes a  dull against a very very strong grand  master  i think i think i think it's it's  definitely a happier ending for for  johan sebastian here because yeah faisal  is it's a good result on paper but he  was completely dominating that game for  the entire game